the Joe Rogan experience what other
steps do you think can be taken to sort
of alleviate or at least somewhat
mitigate this awful crisis well of
course there's narcan and you know what
that is it's the like the miracle opioid
overdose reversal drug in nasal spray
usually and so if someone has overdosed
on opioids fentanyl heroin pills
whatever you know if get these sprays
they will bring them back to life
literally right and so you know that
it's available in some places oh man I
am not smart enough to know that see if
we can find out narcan see if we can
find out how narcan works
how does narcan work um that's amazing
though they figured out something that
can know from like where else where what
else is do we have that in pulp fiction
you know to the heart remember that we
would have seen you know what I was
asking someone about that recently and
that is total [ __ ] that is like
Quentin Tarantino just making something
up that big dramatic scene was [ __ ]
awesome
yeah that's pretty crazy I mean if you
could shove off [ __ ] needle in the
middle of your heart pump that stuff in
like wow and she pops up to life with a
needle out of her chest yeah that's in
real life it would have been a nasal
spray to the nose yeah but this is 1994
they didn't have they did and so
nowadays it's like firefighters
librarians these are the people who are
encountering opioid overdose victims
they're encountering them in the library
in the lab library to do drugs or
firefighters or EMTs react to people
that are overdosing right yeah and isn't
it the case that some fentanyl overdoses
the the people actually have it on their
skin so these people that are helping
them with the police officers or first
let's see another thing that's kind of a
snopes.com thing they started that ya
know that's you can't get it from you
can't get an overdose by touching
fentanyl it won't go into your skin if
someone like there was a you know a
mound of fentanyl someone sneezed and it
was in the air you could get it by
breathing in but by just touching it now
oh well that's good to know it's the
best narc
singing overdose it says närcon has a
strong affinity to the opiate receptors
a stronger affinity to the opiate
receptors than opiates opioids like
heroin or percocet so it knocks the
opioids off the receptors for a short
time this allows the person to breathe
again it reverses the overdose holy [ __ ]
man that person needs a Nobel Prize
never they need the exact opposite as
the guy who sold the drugs to Prince
yeah yeah exactly you know they need
love and respect
yeah that's an amazing discovery so
that's good to know because we've
actually I think probably repeated that
someone told me that did I ever repeat
that on the show that people have to
work drugs or gloves when they're
handling people with drug overdoses have
you ever heard of a car fence no what is
that it's a hundred times stronger than
fentanyl it's analog resis uses like an
elephant tranquilizer and so in one of
the Jurassic Park movies that's what
they use to tranquilize the dinosaurs oh
yeah that's right and so I I interviewed
a bunch of dark web dealers for the book
I even actually like met one in person
what do you look for well he asked me
not to say but I don't have to say look
he was like a buff dude he was like he
very much he's too much we're gonna find
him now like when you were recording
like Oh what is that orange VAT of you
know did you do that kind of same [ __ ]
when you're talking to him no no because
he knew I was a journalist I told him I
was and he wanted to say yeah he just
he's like people think of us as scum but
I want to tell my story and that's
that's what journalists like live right
what is his story well he was a he's
probably listening to this man hey bro
that's crazy he was a drug dealer total
family man with his daughter he was like
feeding her french fries and stuff but
he had he was addicted to meth at one
point he had a lot of sort of depression
self-esteem issues but then he tried to
opioids and he said it was like an
antidepressant it
you know so became hooked and so he
started selling fentanyl on the dark web
because it he didn't want his kids to
have to live in poverty he didn't wanna
his his drug addiction to interfere and
so not only that but he he claims that
he's helping addicted users more
affordably maintaining their habits so
he is this big like [ __ ] you know Purdue
Pharma anti-government anti-big pharma
mentality so he blames like Purdue
Pharma made oxycontin pills and God
that's how the whole opioid epidemic
began so it was first it was the pills
then people switched to heroin and now
it's fentanyl is in all the heroin and
so this guy says that because he makes a
nasal spray to and he says that people
can buy his fentanyl nasal spray on the
dark web for like 60 bucks take one
spray it's equivalent to one oxycontin
pill and that's enough to maintain their
addiction and so he says you know
instead of paying money to the big
pharmaceutical companies people buy this
it's much cheaper and so he had a whole
moral justification of how he did it so
he's an ethical drug pusher that's that
was his case the problem is that this
stuff fentanyl is so potent and and to
make it into a nasal spray you have to
use this whole thing it's called
volumetric dosing when the water and you
got to get the exact right proportions
and he's not a trained pharmacist
you know just buying it he's a middleman
no no no he does it he may he has a
whole process how he does oh yeah but
he's not a trained pharmacist he doesn't
you know no he's doing it right that
wasn't so I told him that I said that to
him and he's like well basically I
tested on myself so if I'm doing it
wrong I would die so my customers
therefore know I've tried it so that guy
sounds like he's got a great pitch but
I'm not sure yeah I mean you got to
justify yeah I get it but so many people
who sell drugs and so many people who
were involved
often drugs there are always the people
have [ __ ] up lives like to paint the
best version of what they're doing yeah
that's what that sounds like yeah I mean
I feel like if you're selling fentanyl
someone's probably died because of what
you sold them I mean it's just it's one
of those things where it's so deadly
[Applause]